歡迎收看
李台大人秀最受歡迎的教學單元
標谷在現等
要請主老師幫我們把名字進起來
因為現在台股已經創了歷史新高
一直往上跑
都已經到了2萬0800點的附近了
這個在漲下去就要2萬1000點了
真的太厲害了
現在才第一季剛過完
所以今天我們要教一個
稍微進階一些些的東西
之前朱老師常常耳提面命是
要會停損
要守紀律
可是到這個階段
我們應該要教的是
要會停立
有一些東西是要教你
怎麼賣
好多人在問
我賺了錢 我不會賣
今天這一集一定要好好地看起來
就是教你各種賣出的技巧
朱老師
我們希望大家都已經變師傅了
對
因為賣股是師傅
對 要會賣股票
不然的話 指數創進高
結果不會賣 它又跌回來
對 最怕這樣了
反正你有一個觀念
股票怎麼漲 總有一天會跌
對 不可能漲到天漲
不可能永遠漲
對 那尤其你有賺到錢的人
但是呢 有的人賺到錢
他又怕 會怕明天跌
他又賣得太早
所以我們賣股票
還是要看幾個訊號
所以我今天特別把這幾個很重要的訊號
尤其現在大家都在追股票
股票很強
那你追到手上的話
如果有這些狀況
你是不是也可以去練習
去賣賣看
當你賣了幾次了以後
你就有心得了
以後你就會賣股票
所以我們說會賣才是高手
賣股票是師傅
那我們今天就來告訴大家
三個很重要的訊號
那第一個
如果你是沿著五軍上漲
你的獲利超過十趴了
那你自己可以算嘛
比如說這支五票
我買的時候一百塊
現在已經看到一百億了
那表示你已經賺到十趴
那這時候你就要準備停利了
十趴我就要準備停利了
當然在短線來說
十趴已經很多了
已經很多
而且我一直有一個觀念
做股票不要貪心
你知道你做一次十趴
做十次呢
就一倍啦
哪有那麼好的事
如果你做十次都10%啊
對不對
如果你超過10%了
我們就簡單的說
跌破5日均線你就賣
一支股票你在旗掌的地方買吧
那一直漲一漲
你看我已經賺10%了
什麼時候賣呢
你就跌破5日均賣
跌破5日均賣 跌破5日均賣
那就看
他漲多少你就跌破5日均
所以不一定是10%賣
如果漲到10%
還是沒有跌破5日均
那你就再繼續包
那你當然這一趟的獲利就非常高了
可能漲15% 20%
可是你就跌破五均賣
我們就看最近我們
大家都在討論很強的股票
比如說這支試電
這個地方開始多頭
我們一定要從多頭開始做多
沒有變多頭千萬不要進來
他開始多頭了 我在這裡買
他沿著五均走走走
各位自己也可以去算
你買進來 到這個位置
你大概已經有10%了
所以你跌破五軍你就賣
那賣完了 當然我們在教學
都告訴大家 告訴過大家
多頭區是沒有變 你就要繼續做
而不是說賣完了
這支股票我就不管了
所以當他回來修正
這個地方又是一個
回後買上漲的一個買點
那各位看過我們前面的這些教學
這個應該都聽得懂
這個地方是回後買上漲
然後這一次更不得了
這一次10% 20% 30%
所以跌破5均就請你賣
那賣完了現在又回後買上照
這個一直到4月到現在
你看高點到344.5了
那你當初買的時候大概310
所以這根紅K又到10%了
所以你又要準備跌破5均賣
那如果這支股票你看你做一次
做兩次 做三次
都賣在相對的高點
而且你的獲利都很好
如果你做到一支好的股票
他真的多頭趨勢不變
那沿著五軍就這樣子
也入座上去
那我們看東洋也是一樣
這是一個多頭 對不對
回後買上漲
那這個地方都沒有跌破五軍
或者是他不漲
可是你沒有到10%
這裡沒有10%
可是這樣就好難熬
當然 做夠股票
不可能每天都漲10%
那就是說你抱一抱嘛
抱一抱長這個地方
再來這裡差不多這裡到這裡
大概就有10%了
那你跌破5均賣
還是一樣喔 回後買上漲
那這一根就10%了
還有這兩根
所以你已經超過10%了
跌破5均賣
就很簡單
強的可能他就一直漲
那有的可能會漲一天
休息兩天 又漲一天
那你看超過10%跌破5均賣
那這是做短線最簡單的一個停歷的方法
因為你跌破5G賣
基本上你的貨利已經入袋了
那如果他沒有回後買上漲
他就一直跌了
那你已經走掉了
就不會發生那個賺的錢
又到吐回去的這個狀態
這是第一種停歷的方法
而且是大家最經常要用到
是 也比較容易
對 也比較容易
你就是五日軍線研究所就好
很容易 對
心情不容易而已
就是有的時候他兩三天不長
也要再抱一抱就是好
稍微忍耐一下
那第二種也是一個很重要的現象
我們買進去以後
長到高檔
你看到有兩天都出大量
最近也蠻常見的
常常看到這種股票
到高檔爆亮
可是第二天他又爆亮
已經有兩天
有可能是兩天都是黑的
也可能有紅有黑
那是連續兩天的大量
結果你發現
他跌下來
把這兩天跌破了
你就要趕快離開了
這表示這兩天的人
主力已經跑掉了
而且這個很容易發生什麼
一日反轉
他很容易就變成一直往下跌
所以如果你也有獲利
你獲利很高
比如說今天第三天
哇 爆大量了
那明天 因為是紅的
紅的 我們就繼續報 也沒跌破五軍
那明天又看到了 可能就留一個小黑
可是又是一個大量
那這裡 你就要注意這兩天的大量
不可以跌破 那跌破你當然就停利
因為我們今天介紹就是停利
就是你有賺錢要趕快跑
好 我們看這個
好 這個 好
前面這個是ok
多頭女去做 超過10%
你是不是都賣掉了 跌破五軍
那你現在不是按照機率
回後買上早 我又買了
然後第二天 這個休息
第二天 就出了大量
那還可以爆了
再來又出大量
而且這是一個變盤線
那你後面假設你捨不得賣
可是這兩天的大量跌破
你就要趕快賣了
這個可能沒有賺到什麼錢
但為什麼要賣
因為這個後面很容易
就會轉成空頭
你不賣的話 還會倒賠
散戶朋友可能很容易這一天賣了以後
覺得不是談上來了嗎
賣錯了 對不對
那可是你談上來
其實當然這個以後
我們還有很多比較進階的教學
其實這個談上來
你是不能買的
而且如果真的運氣好
他隨便是 他隨便是回後買上漲
但是你不是
剛才我們已經講了
這有兩個大量
所以你根本是過不去的
你這個紅K這種量根本就過不去
所以以後我們到進階就會告訴大家
有一些位置的狀況
你最好不要買
因為過高的機率很低
不是說絕對不過
那我們做股票賺錢的
最重要的一個核心概率
你就概率
就是我們要高機率
對 你要機率高我才做
那這個更不用講了
一路上漲已經超過
超過兩成三成
所以這個跌破
你去武軍你就會賣
好了賣了以後
你可能還準備賣
但是你有發現
一天兩天三天的大量全部跌破了
這三天的大量跌破
這次股票就沒有了
所以你去發現後面
根本就沒得做了
所以你剛好就按照紀律停利
然後你就跑掉了
然後三天大量跌破了
他後面也沒有機會做了
那這個紅K當然不能做
因為他已經跌破月線
這個我們已經交過
做多頭一定要在月線上
不可以在月線下去做
那做了後來你還是要多了一個停損
好
我們看第三個訊號
第三個訊號也是最經常發生的
而這個訊號又經常發生在標股
就是每天早每天早
那你一看到這個訊號
就一定要趕快跑
好 要跟標股說分手
出場停利訊 高檔出現爆大量長黑K
或者是長黑吞噬
如果爆大量長黑K
沒有把昨天的紅K跌破
那你可以先賣一半
因為這個大概都是連續上漲
連續上漲你的獲利應該都超過15%
那你就先賣一半
雖然他還沒有跌下去
他是還沒有跌破昨天的低點
那你就先賣一半
那第二天如果再往下當然你就要全部跑
假如今天就已經把昨天的紅可以吃掉了
那你今天就要全部賣掉
因為這是
一日反轉的最嚴重的K線訊號
我們在技術分析裡面
有很多的訊號 有的是
訊號比較弱 有的訊號比較強
你碰到強的訊號一定要立刻執行
所以執行力蠻重要的
所以會賣股票就是當機率段
知道這個已經沒有機會了
所以你就要趕快跑掉
那這種大部分都是連續標股
那你做到了你本來就很高興
你做到這種
你在這裡買對不對
漲停 漲停 漲停
這一隻很經典耶
很經典吧
一大咖空 一路咖
可是你一看到黑K
把昨天跌破你就一定要賣
你趕快跑 不跑後面
那天漲停到跌停吧
對 漲停到跌停
這個以後我們進夜班也會告訴大家
漲停到跌停要怎麼辦
你總不能看著它一直到跌停嗎
對啊 到底還賣不掉
最後還鎖跌停
鎖跌停第二天還會開低
還有一個低點
那你又嚇得賣掉了對不對
這個以後我們課程都還會有
所以大家要持續的
你真的很佛心
是
OK啦
這個反正你至少知道你在這裡賣嘛
然後長黑吞噬你也賺錢
大概還賺兩成喔
很高的利潤
好
你買金了以後又好高興喔
這個不是嗎
你看買金了以後
哇 又漲漲漲漲
可是呢 今天這個長黑就不好了
而且配合大量
應該是八九不離十
八九不離十
可是呢 還沒有跌破五軍啊
也沒有跌破紅
那你就先賣一半
那第二天真的沒跌
那你還有一半
再來你就沒有什麼考慮
那真的又跌破紅軍
你就賣
那這個都給你證明
你看大量長黑
後面的紅K就過不了高
是
對不對
只是因為我沒有賣
所以還抱著
但如果你空手千萬不要買
你空手買在這
你就變停損
不可能這樣跌
你這樣疊的話
就代表你沒有停順
是
那我希望有看過我節目
或我教學的都不要被套牢了
最多一個停順
那你這個大疊就跟你沒關係了
對不對
因為今天教老師賣出
當然有一個前提
你的買進點要正確
如果買進點正確
你一定可以享受到這種
10% 20%的停歷 甜蜜點
那也不要覺得
我一定要賣在最高
我現在賣就沒有比前天高
沒有比昨天高
訊號出現了我們手機率
不用賺最多
可是賺得要入袋
對
接下來就要請大家
訂閱一下我們的榮耀班了
因為我們要教大家最近
已經有停歷訊號的一些
熱門股